this video is sponsored by surf shark so
the wheel of time came and went passing
as most fantasy adaptations these days
do as just another in the mass-produced
post-game of thrones industrial complex
and like most of those shows it is
inoffensive bland and uninspired this is
different though you see because
i actually care about this one and this
shows not bland it's bad it's not good i
do not like it i'm a little tired of
people letting it off so easy sure its
effects are uneven and it frequently
looks like a cw show but i don't really
care about that the heart of the show is
broken it's machine is falling apart but
how and why uh it hits familiar beats
and let's admit has some pretty great
moments and yes i recently made a video
criticizing exactly this kind of media
bad discourse i am conducting right now
but i actually don't intend to trash the
show i care a lot about the books and i
am friends with many in the wheel of
time fandom many of whom are just happy
they have an adaptation at all i am not
here to hate actually it's the opposite
i think the wheel of time is awesome i
read the first couple of books and found
them enchanting fun and full of
imagination the purpose of this video is
to explain in intense detail why the
show is substandard it fails not just as
an adaptation but as a season of
television i want to judge the show as
if the books never existed i want to
figure out why the writing in this show
so often lacks purpose and drive for the
record i do think the show is a very bad
adaptation of the source material but
that's not criticism alone all
successful adaptations differ from their
source material to some degree i'm far
more interested in analyzing the lazy
writing that consumes the show but
before doing that i have to explain the
biggest single adaptational change that
ruined the show that proved an
insurmountable issue from beginning to
end part one the whodunit for those of
you who don't know the wheel of time is
a 15 book epic fantasy series written by
robert jordan and completed by brandon
sanderson though i haven't completed the
series i've had to describe to me that
the first three books are adventure
quest fantasy stories they follow a
similar lord of the rings narrative and
the following 11 books are political
fantasy stories more like dune season 1
of the wheel of time pretty much follows
the events of book 1 which i have read
it's similar to lord of the rings in a
lot of ways this is not bad because lord
of the rings is awesome maybe if amazon
devoted more time to this show rather
than their lord of the rings spin-off
show we would have gotten a better but
i'm getting off track to put it simply
the show is about a group of young
people plucked out of their boring lives
and sent into danger because one of them
is the chosen one now think about your
favorite chosen one stories star wars
lord of the rings it's pretty clear from
the get-go who the chosen one is right
this is how it is in the wheel of time
books while not explicitly stated at the
start of the book it is assumed that our
main point of view is in fact the chosen
one so spoiler alert i guess for the
show but not for the books rand is the
chosen one we figured it out
we we did it everyone chapter two book
one we realized he's the dragon it's
game over guys maybe the show runners
thought this was too cliche too typical
of a fantasy narrative let's change it
up and keep people on their toes right
let's make it a mystery anyone can be
the dragon reborn
the result however is a show that feels
like it's ashamed of its source material
it becomes a type of whodunit focused
more on misdirection than telling the
main story hell it's even prominent in
their advertising in the books only a
male can be the dragon reborn because it
has to do with the thorough complex and
brilliantly designed magic system uh not
not here though anyone can anyone can be
the dragon while some think they made
this choice as some kind of political
gesture even the girls can be cursed
with evil power and go insane i think
that is ridiculous because i don't think
there's anything flawed about the way
jordan set up that system i think they
did it because they were afraid the show
would be boring they needed misdirection
they were not confident in the source
material alone now it's not just between
these three boys it's between naive
logan hell even moraine can be the
dragon reborn disregarding the break
from the source material in which it is
insanely obvious that rand is the dragon
reborn the issue of turning the story
into whodunnit is that the show is more
invested in keeping you hooked from
moment to moment guessing looking for
the next clue rather than you know
caring about the characters on their own
merits all of these characters have
mostly interesting qualities to them
however none of them are fleshed out
because there's a chance we might ruin
the mystery of the show instead of one
character being the bland chosen one
sorry rand now everyone is the bland
chosen one instead of spending more time
on the drama of their circumstances you
know making it feel real many scenes
exist simply to tease the audience hey
maybe this one's the dragon
but before we continue here's a quick
message about our sponsor surf shark
what is surf shark vpn good question
moraine it's actually a virtual private
network that keeps your online identity
safe by encrypting the information sent
between you and the internet also a vpn
swaps the real location of your device
with a new one this way you can travel
around the globe in your device but you
say there are no phones in the two
rivers or computers i have no idea what
this magic is then i respond to you this
bid is getting a bit unwieldy and maybe
we should move on surf shark has over 3
200 servers in 65 countries when making
this video i had to do extensive
research by watching spider-man on
netflix except it's not in the us see
where i'm going with this access and
unblock content unavailable to your
country it's that simple furthermore
surfshark's clean web feature blocks ads
trackers malware and phishing attempts
allowing you to surf the web safely i'm
still in college but i live an hour away
from campus they don't let me access
their digital library unless i'm
physically there i had a paper due in
two hours the other day and you know
what i did i just put in my school's zip
code and accessed a bunch of articles on
jstor about the merchant of canterbury
or something i didn't read any of the
books use code thing to get 83 off plus
three extra months for free surfshark
offers a 30-day money-back guarantee so
there's no risk to try it the link is
below in the description thank you surf
shark for sponsoring this video and back
we're back to it since i want to be as
exhaustive as possible i really need to
start from the beginning and take us
moment by moment as the show transforms
from decent entertainment to slow motion
car crash all the while these primary
issues will recur again and again and an
assortment of subsidiary issues will
rear their heads too this isn't about
one wrong choice but many part two a
promising start episode one begins with
a bit of exposition and honestly for
fantasy that's not that bad we don't
know where or to whom if he was reborn
as a girl or a boy we learned that
moraine and this guy are out to look for
the next child who may break the world
simple effective intro we love it and
then sort of bafflingly we get a second
teaser that has little to do with the
books but let's look at it on face value
this is a fine way to open your show
despite the air force one level of
visual effects we witness visually what
moraine just described there are others
like moraine looking for the dragon who
wear red and are bad also this guy is
tripping balls there's no one else here
what is that about well we're not gonna
know for a while because this episode is
about
cramming all our early narrative beats
into one episode so that please don't
change the channel please just keep
watching please please please dear the
issue of course is that people have more
patience for establishing characters
than they think i can't help but think
episode one would have been vastly
improved if it had been split into two
parts or if the cliffhanger was right
when the trollux attacked but i'm
getting ahead of myself moraine and her
companion bodyguard splash totally
platonic friend are on the hunt for the
true dragon not a real dragon but a
chosen one a frodo a harry potter etc
based on prophecy they could be a number
of young people from a specific region
and of a certain age except when later
it could be anybody who knows it's just
vibes at this point let's establish our
main heroes after a pretty great title
sequence and i know this isn't that
noticeable but i'm not sure why there's
this awkward slow zoom in for a couple
of these establishing shots here's two
of our leads nainiva naguyan and in what
is an okay addition to the show naive
pushes aguin into the river when
inducting her into the women's circle
it shows that naive is kind of pushy get
it she knows best and aguain is maybe a
little uncertain about her future after
a heavy-handed metaphor about going with
the flow or something we meet our guy
rand who has zero personality and his
dad who is maybe liam neeson let's stay
down
your mother could drink rand loves
iguane which is a problem we shall soon
see later we get to see rand's pals matt
and parent one is boring and the other
is just bad at gambling
they talk about some spooky stuff
happening in the next town i wonder if
that will be relevant later all of this
is pretty standard however tastes like
the first act of a short film episode
one has some of the best moments of the
show with some of the worst pacing i
understand the writers were limited to
eight episodes but how does that excuse
so much bloat and wasted time later in
the show we established perrin and rand
as caring people they truly look after
matt and want to protect him laguaine
walks in like she's [ __ ] garth brooks
or something
and ran doesn't look too pleased what
you say i thought he loved her i'll get
to that later when moraine and land
arrive we get the full picture
this dramatic intro cues the viewer into
seeing this not as the heir to game of
thrones but to peter jackson's lord of
the rings in many ways this is great the
tone certainly fits the first book of
the wheel of time which is in essence a
very loose retelling of fellowship the
wheel of time is by jordan's own words a
more realistic account of what a chosen
one narrative would be though the show
is attempting a tone similar to lord of
the rings trilogy there's a certain
how shall i call it marvelization that
infects the show mostly with quippy
weiner-ness dialogue used to alleviate
tension rand and aguain finally get
their time alone together the conflict
here is that the guayne wants to join
the women's circle and become a wisdom
like naive but to do so would mean she
could never marry anyone seriously
they're just gonna [ __ ] in the middle of
this public space okay earlier we got a
glimpse at the writer's attempts to
humanize parent and matt because in the
first book they are pretty boring kids
who happen upon a crazy adventure they
change in the process sure but at the
start they're pretty much unmolded clay
of course we have to change that don't
we how could we relate to characters who
don't have some kind of tragic backstory
but really the bigger issue is part
three aging up the characters was a bad
idea not to wax poetic on the beautiful
simplicity of the eye of the world too
much but it really is a marvel how
jordan builds this magnificent world and
shows it through the eyes of his
massively naive teenage protagonist they
have so much more to overcome and are
learning about everything pretty much as
the reader does this makes exposition
more seamless and gives room for our
characters to develop as people contrast
that to well perrin has a wife
hold on let me say that again parent has
a wife this may honestly be the most
controversial choice of the show just
based on how unpopular it was on its
surface hardly a problem but when during
the trollic raid still in the first
episode perrin accidentally kills his
wife
we get bigger problems not only is this
a really outdated trope called fridging
it causes so much more problems than it
solves so this all leads me to the
question
why why age up the kids at all were they
afraid they wouldn't catch the adult
fantasy viewers from game of thrones
that's what i suspect because this feels
like a studio mandate it's not like game
of thrones had children characters who
grow up over the seasons why can't the
wheel of time age up its characters over
time especially since they're so
insistent on focusing on moraine as a
main character in the first season this
would solve a lot of the characters
general blandness from the start and
would allow them to get molded by the
strange events they encounter much like
lord of the rings the tavaran are naive
kind people who must face a cruel world
would you call samwise or frodo bland no
not after witnessing their courage and
strength would we relate to sam moore if
he had a tragic incident in his past
where he
i don't know killed a kid with his car
vehicular manslaughter wouldn't make sam
a better character i don't know why the
writers think giving perrin and matt
tragic backstories would make them more
interesting as we shall see it is quite
the opposite especially in parents case
you see in the books perrin is a big
fellow he is very nervous about
accidentally hurting someone he is a
gentle giant essentially he's a sweet
guy but no we need a reason and oh boy
do they give us a reason he's not just a
naturally peace-loving guy it's that he
is traumatized from murdering his wife
accidentally
when i first saw this eye like many
others was very intrigued wow what will
they do with this this is wild and dark
and sad this must go somewhere and boy
were we misled it turns out if you put
the most intense trauma on a character
right from the start they really have
nowhere to go for a long time if they
grow past this trauma too soon they seem
callous if they realistically are
burdened by this trauma forever and are
depressed for most of the show that is
just not dynamic it's like the writers
needed to fix a pipe with a hammer so
they drove a bulldozer through the
building this would be fine if the
writers were sincerely interested in
dealing with this new pairin apparent
unrecognizable from the book series but
no turns out they just hoped this would
add a little spice to his character a
little edge and it turns out ruining him
was the best method similarly the
writers take this method with matt by
giving him a comically over-the-top evil
family you're going to be just like your
dad damn
like him
his mom is cruel and his dad is a
flanderer matt is good though because he
takes care of his sisters a bit cliche
but fine this makes way more sense than
parents alteration we establish matt as
a human decent guy who just so happens
to have issues with stealing and
gambling okay again so much of this
would have been solved if the characters
were
young teenagers anyways let's get back
to our other leads randy gwain and
oh are we already at another part part
four randy gwain bad following their
little argument in the end rand and
iguain have a chat atop this beautiful
mountain rand talks about how he
imagines raising a family in the two
rivers and even before a gwen can say
hey i choose being a wisdom over
continuing this relationship rand says
i'm going to
i already know because he understands
that this is what iguain truly wants he
loves her and knows that he needs to let
her go and be who she is it's difficult
but rand handles it with a great deal of
maturity as you shall see we retrace
this conflict over and over and over
again between these two characters it is
so prevalent that at the climax of the
whole season ran's big moment of victory
is when he realizes that aguain would
never want to raise kids with him
because she is independent and wants to
be a nice to die this is a non-victory
this means nothing from the very
beginning rand is understanding the
conflict retraces itself when agueen
pursues rand later on she doesn't really
change from her main choice she simply
struggles with the effects of her choice
now here's a question for the writers
why why would they resolve this
emotional conflict so quickly only to
retrace these story steps why couldn't
there have been more uncertainty in
aguain's character in the book gwen's
conflict is far more complex than
choosing between her boyfriend and her
career she never is with rand there is
only a presumed love started in
childhood that their families fostered
between them aguain is torn between
pursuing rand pursuing a life as a
wisdom with naive and pursuing a life as
an eye sedai with meringue she is torn
by these complex life choices there's a
slow burn will they won't they
throughout the books which adds suspense
you see there's a sense of progress in
the relationship it's building towards
heartbreak or resolution in the show it
starts in heartbreak then just retraces
the effects of the heartbreak i think
this is a major reason why people find
their bickering annoying in episode 2.
while this may be realistic yes it makes
aguain seem unreliable and rand seem
immature while yes she appears to want
to be with him again and he i think
rightfully is upset that she walked back
what she wants he does overreact and is
kind of a dick and therein lies the
issue stories must progress they must
move forward it feels like there is no
fundamental issue between them they are
both good people who clearly belong
together remember the office good show
right when pam and jim got together that
was great now remember the messy
realistic stuff later on when they had
fights and made ups and had fights and
made up it was boring because they
weren't progressing together retracing
an issue over and over is not character
development but let's get back to
episode one for a bit we've already
encountered issues with perrin and
matt's slapdash characterization but now
naive needs it she hates moraine and
distrusts the i said i in the books it's
because everyone hates them literally
they are like terrifying villains but
since the town doesn't seem too hostile
towards moraine we need a good reason as
to why naive hates her they call you a
leader in this town wisdom and here you
are claiming
this pool is sacred it's an honour to
clean it it's not because moraine is
insanely condescending to her no it's
because the wisdom who raised naive was
rejected by moraine's school or in other
words she was denied entrance to the
white tower and when she got there your
sisters took one look at her rugged
clothes her peasant accent
and they turned her away i think this
bit of backstory isn't terrible but it
weakens her character from the book in
the book naive is young for her title
and must stand up to scrutiny moraine
looks down on her the whole world
dislikes isa yet naive is the only of
the bunch to stand up to her this is why
i love her in the show we're given the
impression that naive holds a personal
somewhat unfounded grudge against
moraine it is implied that since the
woman who raised her sought entrance to
the tower naive will come around to the
idea and become and i said i herself
they framed this like naive standing up
to the elite the only resolution then
will be naive setting aside her personal
resentment and accepting her fate as an
eye to die i guess we'll have to wait
and see let's skip ahead a bit to the
moment we've been waiting for the
inciting incident
i got dandruff on my balls basically a
bunch of trolls attack and to give the
show credit a lot of care was put into
the practical effects as you can see in
this behind-the-scenes footage let's see
if this care holds true to the end of
the season
okay we'll get to that later from here
episode 1 should have ended but instead
we get everything jammed in perrin
killing his wife ninety being taken by
trollix an interesting if an essential
change from the books and ran's dad
fighting for survival in a scene that
occurs off screen in the books we get
the bulk of our action this is the best
action sequence of the show sadly and
the coolest application of magic see how
beautifully they choreograph this
sequence it demonstrates the symbiotic
relationship between lan and moraine and
shows creative applications of the magic
moraine destroys a building just to
throw bricks at these things
obviously this is a great improvement
from the books which told the entire
raid as word of mouth since we were in
rand's pov the whole time so parent
kills his wife like i said and naive
gets taken by the trollix the first of
our official fake out deaths and
honestly the least offensive from minute
45 to 51 is our denouement wherein our
group is gathered and departs on their
journey six minutes and 10 seconds for
all of the characters to get in the loop
witness the damage to the town learn
from lorraine that they specifically
must join her because they are important
and they will leave their town in danger
if they stay rand's dad getting healed
by moraine and them all departing with
the seeming understanding and approval
of a stunned town
it's a lot and the weakest part of this
episode again they should have ended
episode one at the start of the trollope
raid but i digress this ending lends
only to the sense that they had no time
to properly set up their epic fantasy
series if i were to give this episode a
rating i'd give it a solid 6 out of 10.
they got a lot accomplished in a mere 51
minutes part five episodes two and three
episode two begins with a really flashy
but admittedly cool drone shot and
introduces us to the other bad guys the
white cloaks how do we know they're bad
because they are cartoonishly villainous
and beak and feet cut the inside of your
mouth i think it's fine to have such
comical mustache twirling villains as
long as the show is somewhat self-aware
to me this performance felt silly what
we need to know is that the white cloaks
hate the icidi and systematically murder
them now our mary gang is fleeing
trollix and face trouble at terran ferry
when moraine is like these trolls can't
swim so let's destroy the fairy and the
guy who owns the fairy is like but oh my
son
what about my son he foolishly hops into
this raging whirlpool and moraine a
little more concerned with you know
saving the world allows him to die and
somehow she is despised by the other
characters randa takes on naive's role
in the book who is at this moment
presumed dead he complains about moraine
and suggests they have little reason to
trust her i mean he's right that night
moraine teaches a curious aguain what it
means to be an eye to die and
demonstrates that she has a small spark
of power herself this is a terrific
scene 10 out of 10 no notes a great
demonstration of the magic it also makes
sense for aguain's character who having
just lost a naive and her role in the
women's circle is reaching out to join
something greater than herself now let's
get to the [ __ ] and thankfully this
episode only has this small amount aguin
snuggles up to rand after informally
breaking up rand very understandably
says he wants to be alone because you
know what he doesn't deserve to have his
heart toyed with anyways rand vomits up
a bat but don't worry they're all having
crazy visions and all are getting uneasy
with the journey tensions are high rand
gets super aggressive and accuses
moraine and he starts acting like a big
old baby horse is arrested oh no no no
where are we going why should we trust
you he accuses a gwain of being on her
side leguin is a major marine stand
which who isn't and calls rand a
stubborn bastard my reign has done
nothing but protect us tried to keep us
safe then here comes the zinger if i
would leave you
[Music]
so what is the problem here rand and
gwen are post-breakup at this point and
they still want to be with each other
they are retreading an old status either
more breakup or more love we're
retracing their conflict something that
was presumably resolved in episode one
neither are totally right in their
actions however rand comes off worse
because he's acting like a man child
leguin just wants to have her cake and
eat it too again i feel like this
conflict would be improved if rand and
aguain were still at that will they
won't they face in their relationship
the audience would be rooting for a
status they have never seen between them
instead the audience is looking forward
to more of the same if they get back
together we're at stage one and if they
stay bitter and broken we're getting
more of the same at least their
bickering was short because we're once
again fleeing trollix and oh wait the
other bad guys are here and they are bad
all those who seek passage through our
land must be properly
question this is a great setup and
payoff actually earlier moraine
explained to a gwain how iso can't tell
lies they get around that by bending the
truth through clever phrasing and
omission moraine does just that when
being questioned by white cloaks you
wouldn't believe me if i told you
it was a monster sir
eight feet tall with a
with a mouth like a boar
a group of them overtook the village we
were in later marine tells the tavarin a
long ass story about the people from
their village their king eamonn liking
the song had sent messages to the
neighbors they'd fought for in the past
and they were promised aid if they could
hold for three days this to me goes on
too long but hints at the type of pace
that could have been paced closer to the
lord of the rings a pace that could have
given an epic way to the show because
the show has such a breakneck pace it
feels out of place and apparently the
showrunner fought to keep the scene in
honestly great it also provides a bit of
foreshadowing to the last episode
moraine's wound appears to be causing
her significant health problems and land
can't get her to slow down now we get a
phrase preceding every classic argument
do you want to talk about it rand says
that they can't go back to the way
things are she made her decision lacking
any real retort to this oguen says that
she will never be naive's apprentice
because she is dead i'm not going to be
nainie's apprentice because she's dead
she tells rand and i just want you to
look at me and not hate me which fair
rant says i can never hate you and
see what i mean this back and forth is
tiresome aguin is being unrealistic and
not allowing rand time to heal and rand
is just acting like a dick while leguin
is right nainiv is dead it doesn't
change the fact that she made a choice
she chose to leave rand it's kind of
like a person choosing to break up with
someone because they got a great job in
another city then suddenly that job
doesn't work out and they expect things
to go back to normal but how can that
work when you've shown your priorities
and even in this situation with naive
supposedly dead rain sees that aguain
still wants to join the i sedai where
again they couldn't be together he
understands that what a gwain wants
inherently excludes their relationship
aguin has other priorities which is fine
as long as she allows rand to go his own
way of course they still love each other
and show that in this scene which makes
this all the more annoying it's like
listening to your on and off again
friends bicker every time you go out to
eat anyways paren sees a wolf it hints
that he is special you know and maybe
the dragon
the editing of this scene by the way is
so funny how can you make this cute
little guy look menacing moraine is
totally out of it and in an act of
desperation lan takes the group into a
spooky abandoned city he knows the
trollocks won't enter why won't they
enter ah we'll deal with that later it's
a short-term solution that quickly sours
matt and peron have a really sweet scene
together showing how kind matt is but
even nice guys like to steal evil knives
from spooky cities every now and then
look matt may be a kleptomaniac but at
least he has taste he awakens some kind
of evil force and suddenly this safe
harbor is a scary harbor the group falls
apart and splits up
but not before we get a naive jump scare
whoa whoa if you don't take me to them
right now
i'll slit your throat okay great end of
episode two and i'm gonna say it the
strongest episode 7 out of 10 it feels
like the most even all around and
surprise surprise sticks closest to the
books episode 3 is when things start to
get
well let's just say there may be a
reason why our advanced screening only
showed the first two episodes because
episode 3 is not very good our teaser
shows how naive escaped her captors and
killed a troll there's no stakes because
we know she prevails but still awesome
we love it at this point our fellowship
is broken when situations should get
more tough they somehow get easier rand
is with matt agueen with perrin and
moraine land and naive are all together
the clear highlight of the episode is
lan and naive we see their budding
romance it's a real enemies-to-lover's
arc that contrasted with everything else
is dynamic and shows progress in the
story while their banter is not always
the best you said you tracked me all the
way from the two rivers to sterling
how said you could ask
not let it answer their relationship is
far more interesting than randy naguain
who are simply treading over old ground
maureen's wound is a great dilemma and
naive is forced to help someone she
hates another great demonstration of the
magic system is when naive applies
pressure to moraine's wound and tells
land i've heard about the bond between
an isodiana water that you feel what she
feels so get ready
because this is going to hurt it shows
that moraine and lance bond is both
physical and mental our second best plot
point of this episode is rand and matt
who wander through a gorgeous landscape
honestly geographically what kind of
world is this and how far off did they
wander because this looks nothing like
where moraine is rand and matt debate
whether they should pursue the white
tower or go home which is a non-choice
they can't go home because they will
endanger their hometown rand decides
ultimately to head east to the tower
because that's where he hopes he can
rendezvous with higuain now the absolute
worst duo in this whole episode is
perrin and iguain who really have
nothing interesting between them they
too decide to head to the tower in the
hopes they will find the others they
start a fire and parent asks was that me
or you
we get it they all might be the dragon
karen has an okay dream sequence in
which he relives his wife's death then
we have a jump scare with the main bad
guy in oh boy does he look terrible
his design along with the quality of the
cg makes the dark one look like a
sorceress stone level threat then were
being chased by wolves in a sequence i
can only call spatially baffling
the editing and direction make it look
like a mess with there being no sense of
danger i just really hate this scene
there's no suspense because we never
know how far away the wolves are or in
what direction they're heading clearly
the wolves should catch up with them but
this makes it seem like they outran the
wolves i don't know meanwhile matt and
rand find a town for a while and this is
when everything slows to a halt now i
have to explain the infamous in-hopping
of book one many readers complain that
matt and rand's scenes in the eye of the
world are boring and repetitive
basically they have to fend for
themselves as they travel into in often
sleeping in the dirt and occasionally
playing music to earn a bed is it
repetitive sure but i personally love
these scenes because they demonstrate
just how helpless they are there's
constant danger because we're always
aware of how clueless the kids are much
of this is understandably cut out in the
show however we get this one in sequence
which is sort of a best of hits but
somehow it is neither best of or a hit
let's talk about my favorite character
tom marilyn and how they did him dirty
and maybe this can be treated as a
microcosm of what the show misses
tonally in the book tom is an old glemon
a storyteller and musician he is
introduced in the two rivers and
actually starts out with the tavarian
and moraine he is part of the fellowship
while he does duck out halfway through
the book he is essential to random
matt's survival i actually understand
why the show chose to cut him out of the
start too many elements to introduce
they instead use him to cheat purposes
and in the process destroy his charm you
see tom is a goofy character world weary
but lighthearted over time we learn that
he's seen much more of the world than he
initially lets on on the surface he's an
aged jester figure but underneath he's
an aragorn level badass throwing knives
and whatnot this is how i like to view
the books unassuming traditional fantasy
cloaking a vast wealth of darkness and
intrigue and inventiveness the show
turned him into
this colors of
his morning
[Music]
the darkness of his night they give him
a guitar and make him sing like
nickelback with sex appeal avoiding the
book's lightness the show goes directly
for the essence ignoring what makes him
a unique character in the first place he
enters and exits the show in the span of
two episodes and we couldn't care less
about this grizzled generic guide in
trying to make him stand out they make
him generic and this to be honest is
when the show fully lost me not only is
tom boring he is utterly useless the
guys are getting along fine without him
in the book he teaches them to be
amateur gleaman so they can make a
living and survive and don't even get me
started about his exit because i will
get to that anyways we meet tom and his
boring song and for some reason he
steals from matt
why i guess his purpose is to relate to
matt because he's also edgy and moody
and likes to steal matt starts acting
like a dick all of a sudden for reasons
that will later be revealed and you're
the reason we're in this [ __ ] town to
begin with and rant says go on then
i'll handle this you do whatever you
want like always which is like
objectively false matt has constantly
stood up for his friends and been a
voice of reason in the group but
whatever now matt is chatting with the
innkeeper and can i just say this
dialogue kills me i've got an idea why
don't you tell me what you can do i'll
see if i can find you something back
home i was uh pretty well off horse
trailer thank goodness you're here
everybody
everybody i have a horse trader with no
horses here
does anyone need a horse trader with no
horses
i feel like the writers waver between an
epic lord of rings feel and a quippy
marvel movie what is the purpose of this
long conversation matt talks about
needing only one ticket home however he
says he has people to take care of which
yeah his sisters are the quickest way to
get back when they're gonna need one
ticket this shows that matt is moving in
a more evil direction sure but it's just
talk and doesn't reflect his actions now
we're back to the worst duo and they are
still running from wolves but wait they
meet some brooklyn hipsters i mean
tinkers i think the writers were trying
to accomplish two things in this
sequence and for some reason this
sequence needs to drag on for multiple
episodes here's what it accomplishes
perrin learns the way of the leaf which
is pacifism naturally he likes this
because violence hasn't been so useful
to him in the past and aguein flirts
with this guy which shows only that she
is still in love with rand problem is we
know this stuff already we know parent
is traumatized and doesn't want to use
violence understandably and we also know
aguain is still in love with rand this
isn't the most exciting sequence from
the books either but if that is the case
why not shorten the sequence and
lengthen the much more dynamic and
exciting captured by the white cloaks a
sequence that is hopelessly rushed in
episode 5. not to mention the tinkers
are bland and talk in more whedonesque
quips our fires are open to all
for as long as you need them
and you two
you look like you need them
i don't want to focus too much energy on
the tinkers because while i hate them
deeply this sequence demonstrates how
the writers have nothing to do with
parent or gwen perrin is static
emotionally dead and has nowhere to grow
he learns a philosophy the way of the
leaf that he can apply to his life and a
gwain simply turns down a potential
romance back to matt he's caught by tom
trying to steal money from a corpse they
have a moment of bonding because they
both like to steal i guess not sure why
this show is going with this angle
especially since this moment seems
mostly a convenient time to relay info
about the ideal a race of people that
have no real meaning to us at the moment
and don't really play an important
factor until later on he's an iu but it
is rare to see that color of hair
outside the high heel waist later rand
is flirting with the innkeeper oh
i'm not prying maybe i can help ooh will
he fall for someone besides the grain
will he oh no she's actually evil
what are you doing what are you doing
waiting at this point in the show we've
seen several characters display traits
that may reveal they are the dragon
reborn parrot has his wolves a gwen has
her fire and rand
can knock down a heavy door
but it's not just any heavy door it's
iron wood that door is made of iron with
three men your size couldn't break it
down
this is another example of the bad
whodunit plot in the book this scene
involves rand channeling a bolt of
lightning to explode half of the inn
pretty cool but because we don't want
rand to appear more suspicious of being
the dragon we get the
epic moment of him pushing the door down
here follows one of the goofiest chase
scenes i've ever seen
brandon matt are pretty tall wouldn't
you say and they're running fast they're
pursued by a dark friend who was much
shorter is holding an awkward sword and
is grinning like jack torence from the
shining it seems pretty logical that ran
and matt would just outrun her already
they have a pretty big lead so they
could probably just duck behind the
building but alas she corners them
in this vacant alley i love the blocking
here where ran and matt are clearly
trying to look like they have nowhere to
run but they could just like go back the
other way you know maybe they got tired
maybe their feet hurt maybe dark friends
have way better stamina at least we get
some heavy-handed exposition preceding a
villain's death who are you he wants you
to say have you seen that the wheelchair
turning pokemon everyone comes to school
afterwards we get one of my favorite
lines in the show we're gonna leave now
because yeah they could just run in the
opposite direction tom throws a knife
through her throat and is like yeah
maybe you kids need my help and off they
go on their married journey this scene
is all just so goofy to me because of
the mixed tone this character who was
once so casual and who spoke like it was
2022 is now relating classic fantasy
exposition the episode ends as lan
moraine and naive encounter leandron
another eyes to die and what they did
what they captured the dragon reborn we
captured a man calling himself the
dragon reborn okay mystery solved uh
show's over we got him we got him folks
oh no there are still four more episodes
part six the long crawl episodes four
and five it's at this point that we're
nearing the show's middle i'm not the
first to say that second acts are
difficult to write since this season is
eight episodes episode four is the do or
die moment in the season the bridge to
the second half of the show many i've
noticed defend episode four mainly
because of its shock ending i wouldn't
merely call that a cheap cliffhanger
though as it really doesn't change much
about our fundamental story moraine
needs to find the tavarian and get them
to safety simple as that this is about
urgency and survival even during the
slow midsection of book one robert
jordan keeps the urgency moving
emphasizing the intense danger each
character faces there's no time to relax
so how do we spend most of episode four
that's right we're in the boring episode
at least it starts with an interesting
bit of action and gildan exploring who
logan is and why he was captured while
everyone is looking for the dragon
reborn there are these guys called false
dragons who are powerful channelers but
they don't have that spark you know
mainly they stir up trouble in the book
everyone knows logan is a false dragon
but here we can imagine that some
character we care nothing about is maybe
the important one actually in another
type of show i could believe it but not
the wheel of time which is just too old
school for that i can't help but imagine
audiences getting bored with this almost
completely silent random guy who has
hijacked our narrative thrust again
we're on a straightforward path the
group has split up and they must find
each other in tarvalan but with the
possibility that this is the dragon
reborn how important is moraine's quest
she doesn't seem too confident anymore
this at worst upends our narrative
thrust and at best feels like filler we
know deep down that this is a false
alarm one of our main characters has to
be the big hero but we have to patiently
wait as our characters try to find
purpose again i hate this episode
passionately if episode 3 was a 4 out of
10 episode 4 is a 3 out of 10. none of
this is fun moraine lan and naive are
recuperating in a camp with the other i
sedai they share responsibilities
suppressing logain's powers which is so
difficult we spend half the episode
sitting down and looking constipated
more characters fill the runtime
characters we couldn't care less about
though the show continues insisting we
care a lot about our main story is lost
in a mess of subplots and blunt
character development i don't want to
spend too much time on this episode
because it does so little for the show
narratively but i must discuss it
thoroughly because this was the episode
when i started truly hating the show so
we have these different types of icidae
called ajaz i'm only going to explain
this as deeply as the show presents it
morena's blue kareni is green and
leandron is red because she is evil and
hates men this isn't too far from the
book by the way yet i can't help but
feel this information in world building
is unnecessary at this point in the
story moraine decides to share the
burden of watching low gain not like she
has other stuff to do but whatever
meantime lan seems to be chilling too
he's shooting the [ __ ] with his buddy
guy we're supposed to care about for two
episodes just like tom and just like tom
he is bland as [ __ ]
his name is steppen and he is kareni's
warder just as lan is moraine's water
and what is this conversation doing
between them
isn't here what does it add to the story
these are two characters who will be
spoiler alert both dead by the end of
the next episode they gossip about
moraine and land then reveal to the
audience that leandren is gaining
traction with the others the reds want
to gentle low gain before an official
trial gentling means they remove his
access to channeling making him really
sad so this is some fun politics we're
engaged in we're trying to figure out
whether it's okay to gentle a man before
or after a trial does any of this matter
beyond showing us that the reds are bad
and not good no we already know the reds
are bad they wear red duh 13 minutes and
40 seconds into the episode we finally
get to see where our leads are and
oh oh they're just doing the same stuff
as before aguain and peron continue
their awful adventure with the tinkers
and continue getting lectured about
pacifism we first swear violence and all
instruments of it i suppose this is all
supposed to reinforce peron's aversion
to violence which again i argue doesn't
need reinforcing now's as good a time as
any to discuss scene progress and
character choices let's look at these
few scenes we get with the tinkers our
first scene merely recaps what has
already happened they are uncertain but
make no change in their situation they
are completely passive in this scene
however there is a hint that may change
soon you were wondering the caroline
playing in rags
without food
or gold
your bandits you're not very good ones
the second scene merely reinforces the
way of the leaf and is a scene of
exposition neither character makes a
choice or experiences anything that may
alter their situation the third scene
shows parent and wayne enjoying their
time with the tinkers their situation is
the same but they're less miserable
about it now we get more exposition
about the tinkers and de guain and this
guy flirt with each other following this
even more information about the tinkers
is related to paris finally a gwain is
asked by this guy who is he
the man that holds you heard this scene
could have shown us something aguain
could have been feeling affection for
this man she could have made a choice
that revealed character instead we get
the decision made for us she is in the
same limbo loving rand revealing nothing
except that she and rand belong to each
other so that's paren and aguain this
entire episode that that's their story
does anything change for them at this
point their characters are tools through
which the writers can expose it about
the tinkers they make no choices that
reveal character they make no progress
on their journey and encounter no
obstacles on their path i wanted to
focus on these collections of scenes
because they described so much that
doesn't work in these episodes for a
character to feel real and interesting
we can't just be told about their
problems we have to see them make
choices a choice is not merely deciding
to stay with the tinkers because that
was the status quo a choice reveals an
aspect of their character for example
when naive chooses to help save moraine
that shows that despite her stubbornness
she chooses to place others before her
own interests always we learn something
about her or when aguain chooses to be a
wisdom over pursuing a relationship with
rand that tells us that she is ambitious
and wants an unconventional lifestyle
when again and again going wavers
between wanting rand and not wanting him
we aren't really learning anything new
about her because those aren't choices
that change her circumstance she's
already made the choice that reveals
this aspect of her character we are so
far just reliving the consequences of
that choice when we should be learning
about a new choice something that could
reveal another aspect or layer to her
character this failure to give choices
to our leads presents a real problem in
the show now you may be saying this must
be how the book is they are constrained
by the book on the contrary aguain and
perrin are some of my favorite
characters in the book they must
constantly make difficult decisions for
example before finding the tinkers
there's a scene where they're being
hunted by evil skin shredding crows and
peron must decide whether he will let
going die by crow or if he'll give her a
less painful death with his own axe it
is brutal yeah and he wonders if he'd
even be capable of killing aguain but he
decides he'd do it if only to save her
from the horrors of the crows now that
reveals character that makes parents
seem far more complex doesn't it it's
because in the book our characters are
always making choices here they seem to
be coasting forward save for a select
few back to episode four matt rand and
now tom are doing what they were up to
in episode three just trying to survive
they take shelter at this house in the
woods and we get some more lovely
exposition tom explains all about his
cool backstory and his nephew who could
channel and oh he's gone he's gone now
okay he's just he's gone also matt is
acting pretty strange and evil almost
like maybe he's the dragon to cap off
our terrible time with tom we see matt
wielding that evil scary dagger he stole
from shiddar loga huh almost like it has
something to do with his mood or
something i don't know and tom
intervenes it seems like matt maybe
killed that little girl but there's also
a fade there so guess we'll never know
now i'd like to detail another
half-assed reimagining of a great scene
from the eye of the world i promise i'll
stop doing this just
please let me have this one in the book
they do think tom died after attacking a
fade for whatever reason maybe it's the
rushed editing this scene makes it look
like tom is about to tackle the fade on
his own and matt and rand are just like
peace and duck out abandoning tom
without another worry in their mind and
why should they they just met the guy
we're left wondering what the hell
happened pretty certain tom is fine and
confused about rand and matt's behavior
but don't worry that's the last we see
of these characters for months in the
book tom has been with rand and matt
since day one he's taught them how to be
glemon he's their guide through the
world because of tom's history with his
own nephew he sacrifices himself
ensuring the boys escape to safety in
order to fight the fade it is very
emotional and not taken lightly this is
a big step in random mats growing up and
learning to fend for themselves this
scene cemented tom as one of my favorite
characters here in the show he's just
some guy rand and matt used to escape
some trouble it is tragic the bulk of
the episode of course concerns the camp
with low gain the entire focus of the
show is suddenly on this random guy who
may or may not be the dragon in the
meantime land and naive continue their
flirtations and we learn about the
warders and their pansexual lifestyle
none of this is terrible but it does
feel unnecessary when we're losing sight
of our main narrative moraine after
being out for the last episode is more
concerned with this new guy than in
retrieving the lost tavern twenty years
we hunted
and we lost them i lost them when she
tells lan i don't think the dark one has
any more idea who the dragon is than we
do this is when we hit rock bottom all
urgency has dissipated moraine our
supposed show lead has lost sight of her
mission maybe instead of somberly saying
we lost them she could i don't know try
desperately to find them as if any of
this was important at all but no we're
we're building to a cool scene don't
worry just
there's going to be a cool scene later
don't worry about it another example of
a scene that reveals nothing new about a
character is when leandron tries warming
up to 19. liandron is already so
mustache twirling evil we know naive
would not budge to her side this scene
only shows that naive is smart liandron
is evil and we already knew all of that
back in the cave moraine tries to gather
info from logan all of these scenes are
funny because it looks like the i said i
are pooping but wait we're in trouble
now it's an ambush and logan is trying
to break free
logan's army looks like 5 to 10 extras
but whatever we get some last airbender
movie levels of blocking and then
there's some slow-mo fighting in the
forest reminiscent of something on the
history channel everyone fights kareni
dies and before we know it everyone is
in life-threatening condition
lann is going to die but wait naive goes
insane and heals everyone in the great
tradition of fake out deaths finally
they gentle logan before his trial he
sort of forced their hand there naive
holds the final shot and it feels pretty
clear to us that she must be the dragon
reborn she is not but why not let's
pretend she's the dragon now anything to
pad the run time there's honestly more i
could say about episode four cringy
dialogue lazy exposition lacking
character motivation but a lot of this i
already discussed and some of it i will
explore in later episodes but let's talk
about the absolute worst episode of the
season yes
even worse than the finale this is the
two out of ten it's two out of ten i
can't avoid it episode five the big bad
from here not everything improves but at
least it gets more interesting this is
when the show turns into a stagnant pool
you'd think in 8-episode season adapting
a 600-page book would have enough
material to worry about right the issue
would be in compressing not expanding
enter the most egregious filler episode
of the season if last episode felt like
a sidetrack this one mostly concerns the
warder of the isidae who died in the
last episode these characters are not in
the book also they do not advance the
story in any way not that it's necessary
but they basically exist to advance
information we already know about the
bond between warders and aside it's cool
we get to see the aftermath of one of
those relationships but by god how is
this more important than our main story
we start with an overlong funeral for
kareni with one of the most
unintentionally funny pairings of
soundtrack and visuals i've seen
this scene adds nothing and has little
to do with our main characters but we
get some nice shallow graves what an
exciting teaser so a month has passed
and we're all basically still where we
were last time everyone's casually
moving to tar velon hey maybe we could
add some dirt to these cloaks to make
them more realistic no
okay then matt looks like [ __ ] and is
abusing children now i guess
i don't know matt that's some pretty
dragon behavior finally we're at
tarvalon the phallic city let's feast
upon its wonders and oh it's just a
clean set in a studio not to be too
harsh on the production design but you
can feel the attention to detail
faltering a little bit this just doesn't
feel like an expansive place matt and
rand don't go straight to the tower
because they want to shower or something
really rand is just afraid about what
they'll do to matt because he thinks
he's the dragon naive lan and moraine
show up to the tower and naive is just
like you said my people would be here
moraine says don't worry i've got eyes
and ears all over this city they'll find
them okay sure not like rand and matt
just walked through the main gate i love
this dynamic between maureen and naive
naive cares so much about her friends
and it's like maybe i'll have a look
around myself do not underestimate the
women in this tower this is probably the
best part of this episode so for two
episodes the gwen and parrot have just
been chilling with the tinkers but
finally finally we get some conflict the
white cloaks are here and the tinker's
philosophy of pacifism is put to the
test let's see how that goes for them
even if you crush it bury it
burn it
to be clear the tinkers do their best to
protect wayne and parent and this
sentimental moment being broken by the
white cloaks is very welcome
nevertheless they get captured and face
questioning
what is this jump scare with the horse
pretty sure they don't screech like that
but i don't know i don't personally know
any horses these scenes of interrogation
are the most exciting of the episode yet
they are intertwined with the most
stagnant and boring of the whole show
following their capture rand has an
entirely expository conversation with a
new character loyal nothing wrong with
this but it feels like it has no urgency
especially compared to the extreme
danger a gwen and parent face but the
worst the absolute worst crime of this
episode is steppen a character we
briefly met in the previous episode we
had a whole teaser dedicated to his
sorrow after losing his eyes to die the
woman he was meant to protect that
should be enough right actually no
because for roughly 19 minutes of this
58 minute episode we devote our time to
his story what do we learn from this
story and how does it advance the plot
characterization or themes from what i
can tell we get some world building
about the warders but we already got a
good deal of the same material in the
last episode what is it that we're
reminded over and over how important the
bond between warder and isadae is this
seems to be the purpose to reinforce the
bond between land and naive the problem
is we know this already this is
constantly reinforced numerous times
throughout the show in fact this is
really the only thing we know about
their relationship so stephen has a
speech about how we met kareni and the
warders are like yeah man suck she died
then steppen melts her ring in a ritual
ceremony fine but i remind you we
already performed one ritual devoted to
kareni in the three minute teasers so
this feels overdone back to aguain and
parent valda our mustache twirling
villain is trying to prove that aguain
is an eye sadai she just needs to show
her powers or he will kill parent this
is great tension because aguain so
desperately wants to have powers it's at
this time perrin reveals to a gwain that
he accidentally killed his wife so he
feels like he deserves to die aguain
acts predictably and it's like no it's
not your fault eventually aguain manages
a tiny puff of fire which honestly i
love this moment so much
you'll find me harder to kill than that
girl ultimately it is parent with his
mysterious glowing eyes who breaks them
out of there and aguain stabs valda in
the neck and they make a nice little
exit heron doing this is a cool moment
but has little consequence in the book
perrin blacks out and murders a bunch of
white cloaks as they escape reinforcing
his fear of his own violence i think it
would have been cool if he went crazy
and stabbed valda himself only to
further emphasize his fear of himself
but what whatever this this is cool too
while all of this is going on nainib has
yet another dull conversation with
leandron this conversation has little
tension because we already know how
naini feels about joining the evil reds
i feel like the writers want us to think
there's a chance she'll join them but
there is nothing in naive's character or
the presentation of these scenes that
suggest it is even a possibility
immediately after this scene naive shows
up to find random mad i went there and
found the woman you spoke of
it would have been cool if we got to see
the efforts she took to find them but
instead loyal just took it upon himself
to find her which feels lazy and
honestly a missed opportunity to show
how stubborn and persistent nainev is
brandon and nainib have a little chat
about how strong and awesome a gwain is
yeah maybe you could take some kind of
action to try to find her instead of
just talking about her no okay after
apparent and aguain escape moraine and
leandren argue about which side nainiva
will join which continues to feel
useless since i can't believe there is
any actual risk naive will join the red
asha this scene tells us however that
moraine and leandren may be used to [ __ ]
then moraine and alana chat about the
amerlin arriving about how moraine has
no designs on the seat okay all right
it's politics i can't help but feel like
this is horribly timed especially since
we don't really understand who or what
the american seat is yet my
understanding is that the majority of
the later wheel of time books are
politics focused like dude but the first
three books like i said earlier are
adventure quests in order to fill in the
first season they are adding the white
tower politics i understand their
reasoning but i don't think the
execution is successful in order for us
to care about the tower politics we have
to care about our characters and their
goals right now the most pressing issue
is that our group needs to be reunited
and they are so close debating whether
naive will choose one asha over another
means nothing to our main plot point of
who is the dragon and how do we stop the
dark one especially when our most
pressing issue is stalling this tower
stuff should be secondary finally our
least consequential episode ends with
the least consequential sequence steppen
and land go drinking stephen is deeply
depressed as we have seen and been told
again and again land passes out and
wakes up in a panic i i have to say just
this blocking what is this did lan pass
out while leaning on his elbow why did
why is he just sitting like that land
gets up and finds that steppen has
killed himself while the show manages to
put some emotion into stefan's funeral
this is the third death ritual in the
episode it feels over long and again
inessential this would be fine if the
season had all this time to do whatever
but so many great moments are removed
from the book in order to add this this
adds nothing except to tell us yet again
that lan and moraine's connection is
super deep and important my theory is
that the writers of the show had little
confidence in the material they were
adapting kareni and steppen being
characters created entirely by the show
writers are theirs to play with they
don't have to worry about later books or
the dragon mystery they can have their
own story i think they throw their
creative energies into these characters
because that is simply more interesting
to them for a viewer though i have to
ask what is the point so how could this
episode be improved first i think the
capture and rescue of a gwain and parent
by naive lan and moraine could have
occurred in the previous episode that's
how it happens in the book instead the
show loses any urgency how about instead
of another pointless conversation with
leandren eve acts on her instincts and
goes out trying to find a gwen or parent
there was so much missed here in favor
of inessential plot lines or scenes that
repeat the same information again and
again but here's the good news
things are getting better part seven
getting better question mark well
briefly yes things get better episode
six sees our characters finally
reuniting there are some great scenes
brilliant interpretations of the source
material and a building sense of
momentum as we are finally getting back
on track forgive me if i move a little
fast through these episodes because
there are far more interesting things to
focus on on episode eight while these
two episodes are better they don't do
anything extraordinary six is a solid
seven out of ten and seven is a five out
of ten the amerlin seat is the head of
the white tower her name is siwan she
holds a trial with the i sedai to figure
out what the hell happened with logan
why they gentled him etc moraine
controversially keeps information from
the amerlin seat about her secret side
mission with the tavarin after this
moraine and land finally find rand and
matt rand is very hostile
i'm not going to let you hurt him
and moraine is rightfully pissed at
their stupidity
turns out that the evil dagger matt
stole in episode 2 is actually poisoning
him and turning him into an [ __ ]
[Applause]
moraine seemingly fixes this but rand is
somehow still suspicious of her all of
the tension about matt possibly being
the dragon is immediately dissipated
though moraine still tries teasing that
he is stronger than he has any right to
be i don't know
he's stronger than he has any right to
be aguaine and peron are finally at the
tower and aguain is eager to be
moraine's number one student i took
something from them
valde won't hurt any more of your
sisters this is good everyone is finally
coming together now here comes the
standout part of this episode moraine
meets in secret with ceo on the emerald
seat and a bit of subtext is expanded in
the show in the book maureen and cuan
work together evading the suspicions of
the rest of the tower but the show
actually shows a romantic relationship
between the two and i think it adds so
much to their characters and to the show
in general they really added something
great to jordan's story also this line
echoing an earlier line in the episode
is just so hilarious on your knees
on your knees
after having sex see won tells moraine
about her dream and this is really the
spark that brings us to the finale the
heart of every prophecy is the same
the dragon will either defeat the dark
one
or join him and marine says you don't
know which one of them is the dragon
take them all we'd be sentencing the
other four to certain death
maybe maybe not so a lot of maybes here
they're suggesting going to the eye of
the world an actual plot point in
the eye of the world the reason is
flimsy i think since this was merely a
dream shown to see you on but i
nevertheless loved the progress because
finally finally we're going somewhere we
have a goal and stakes the dragon must
go to the eye of the world to stop the
dark one but moraine still doesn't know
who the dragon is and if all of the
contestants go everyone who isn't the
dragon will likely die i personally
don't love the tension of everyone else
possibly dying as it just seems an
excuse to cause friction within the
group but hey it's something it's
conflict anyways naive and aguain
reunite and meet the amerlin seat a
terrific scene displaying their
contrasting personalities aguain is so
eager to be accepted but naive is
clearly the stronger one and the one
siwon is interested in i've been told
you're the most
powerful channeler we've seen in
a thousand years
naini
valmira while this is a humorous scene
it tells us so much about their
characters and hints at the potential
conflict that may arise between the two
friends also this is such a great line
swan sanchez waits for only one woman
and it's not you according to their plan
moraine gets banished from the white
tower for withholding information this
is something they expected and planned
for but it plays out with forced drama
this just felt like the wrong tone for
the scene which is really a triumphant
start to her greater plan so here we are
finally the whole gang's back together
again and ready finally
to continue their mission
okay this is a nitpick but why did they
just chase the horses away like don't
those horses belong to someone everyone
seems on board for the plan cross
through this dangerous portal and quick
travel to the eye of the world so they
can defeat the dark one again
justifiably asks what about whoever's
not the dragon
what happens to them and moraine is like
i don't really know which is funny when
she knows they will all likely die it's
a great example of moraine lying without
exactly lying so they're all ready to go
on their merry way everything is moving
forward then matt just stands there and
they all yell at him and matt just
doesn't join them okay
here's the thing the actor who plays
matt was replaced for the second season
no one really knows why there are
speculations about why but since nothing
seems to be confirmed i really don't
want to spread possible misinformation
regardless his exit is a major blow
especially since he was one of the most
entertaining characters and even more
especially since it appears like
production had to rewrite the finale in
order to fit in his absence because
let's be real matt's decision to stay
makes no [ __ ] sense there's no real
resolution in the finale either he
simply is gone and the characters have
to half-heartedly deal with this issue
sure matt said in earlier episodes about
how he wanted to leave and didn't trust
moraine but he was under the spell of
the dagger and now seemingly cured of
that curse he should be eager to stay
true to his friends we've seen time and
again how loyal matt is so this all just
feels like a mess meant to deal with an
absent actor despite the fumbled ending
this episode had momentum things came
together now we come to our penultimate
episode an episode that does some stuff
right and
so much wrong first off the teaser is
great and has some of the best action
choreography since episode one
the teaser sets up an important reveal
in the ways there's some brief bickering
about leaving matt behind which paints
rand in a terrible light we are not
leaving without him he made his choice
did he what did you make it for you look
rand buddy matt chose to stay behind
overall the waze is a pretty great set
piece it's got that spooky minds of
moria feel also randy aguin seemed to
finally come to their senses
i just want those two little lovebirds
to be happy you know that cg trollic
doesn't look great but the whole
sequence serves its purpose we get our
characters to their new location and we
get increased hostility and suspicion
after the spooky wind tells them all
about their insecurities you'll murder
these children and call it heroism
will never love you as much as you love
them we're now in foldara another city
that on the outside looks pretty cool
but inside is just another bland series
of hallways we also get a brief tease of
pat and feign you know that grinning
dude following them around he just pops
through the gate i really enjoy what the
show is doing to moraine at this point
she is clearly getting exasperated with
the group and desperately wants to know
who the dragon reborn is some of her
actions are starting to seem genuinely
questionable she tells another i said i
to send the red asha after matt like
what the [ __ ] moraine what moraine in
her desperation seeks out men someone
who can kind of sort of see people's
futures i thought this whole scene was
really well done nevertheless moraine
still can't figure out who the dragon is
now here's where things get rocky aguin
tries convincing the others to go to the
eye of the world after moraine's pep
talk i don't want you to die
any of you
but whichever of you goes to the eye of
the world and is not the dragon you will
die there ground to dust between two
forces of nature the others are
understandably upset about likely dying
and aguain doesn't convince anyone i'm
not doing this because maureen said we
should i want to go to the eye of the
world because if there's even a chance
she's right then it's worth it
there is however a stupid love triangle
rand and aguain have a petty argument
gee aren't they good at that about
leaving that behind probably went back
to tavlon for that bloody
again matt chose to stay then we get
this excellent burn
to us
well i guess you're the expert on that
aren't you
karen tries defending aguain and naive
says just stop i am so tired of you two
fighting over her like she's something
you can win this comes out of nowhere
because as far as we've seen there was
never any hint that peron was interested
in a grain like that or vice versa naive
saying this suddenly ignites rand into
accusing paren of liking aguain and
peron is like dude my wife just died can
you not be such a dick the only woman
i've ever loved was my wife
and the whole thing is stupid i hate it
it sucks it's the worst i hate it it's i
it sucks if they wanted to show the
group at their lowest this is not the
way it is forced and the love triangle
lasts only one scene it exists simply to
break them all down so everyone is sad
and naive decides to go stalk land land
just teleports to her jesus christ okay
i love the look lan gives her like yeah
kids love me he really is the whole
package this all precedes a steamy sex
scene which how can any of us object to
that now gwen and rand make up rand says
i don't want to lose you and says she
needs to go to the white tower this is
all basically what rand told her in
episode 1 except replace becoming a
wisdom with becoming a nice to die he
now holds on to the hope that he can be
in her life rand says he can be her
warder one day this scene is
it just something we all expected unlike
nein even land's romance we always
expected a gwain and ran to work it out
we know the whole time what they will
choose now
are you ready for some jarring
storytelling and what is arguably the
worst moment in the show you know how
this whole season was designed to hide
who the real dragon is even though it's
never a secret in the books well here we
are here is the reveal and it just comes
out of nowhere all rand needed was some
post-nut clarity and suddenly he
realizes that he is in fact
the dragon reborn ladies and gentlemen
we got him no matter how fast
you are the dragon reborn we are shown
this information with a hasty montage
rant was actually channeling all these
times rand suddenly remembers that stuff
his dad said to him when he was wounded
in episode 1 and pieces together that he
was the baby born on the mountain and he
fulfills the prophecy this is quite
confusing because we never saw that
scene with rand's dad that was
deliberately held from us in order to
keep the whodunit alive this all feels
like it comes out of nowhere simply
because we're at episode 8 and we have
to reveal things somehow the
satisfaction of the search is totally
destroyed though i am against the
whodunit concept i think it would have
been cooler if we didn't know who the
dragon was until the final episode with
rand showing his true power at the eye
of the world destroying the army and
okay i'm getting ahead of myself a
little bit suffice it to say the reveal
is
lazy in a cool misdirect we see that
rand went to marine's door in the middle
of the night so they could go off in
secret to the eye of the world both
wanting to protect the ones they love
apparently all rand had to say was i'm
the dragon and moraine believes him for
some reason it could have been possible
that rand was only saying this to
protect his friends but
whatever it doesn't matter now because
we are finally
at the end part eight it all comes
crashing down here it is the reason
you're here the season finale the show
could have pulled a win
if they were able to tie up all these
threads and bring some satisfying
moments but i've got to be honest as
much as i love the book the ending is
somewhat anti-climactic somehow the show
still manages to do even worse a lot
worse this is the rise of skywalker of
the season we started off 3000 years ago
a teaser which doesn't tell us much
except the past used to look like the
future this is objectively interesting
but it doesn't really mean much to the
wider episode in fact the conversation
between the earlier reincarnation of
rand and the ambulance seat of that time
period is basically inconsequential we
only know who they are because they
awkwardly state their names to each
other lose serendlemon
anyways moraine and rand are trekking
through the blight which in the book is
a horrifying wasteland with sand worms
and weird creatures here it's just like
a dense forest with a skeleton i get
it's probably a budget thing but come on
some cool fantasy creatures would have
been fun meanwhile everyone else is
trying to figure out what to do now that
moraine and rand ditched them leguin
says i love him and hugs him good moment
but overall no one rushes into high gear
when rand and moraine are gone lan has
to make a choice to leave naive behind
to track moraine down and they have a
touching moment but the fact that naive
knows moraine's tell when tracking her
is so mind-bogglingly stupid she has a
teller i can show you how considering
how warders are pretty much the best
trackers in the world and are known for
tracking down others naive says to land
that maybe she'll be an icidi so he can
be her order lance says i will hate the
man you choose
because he's not me and i will love him
if he makes you smile i like all of this
back in the blight moraine has another
fake out death that is obviously fake
and rand finally stands face to face
with the dark one
and thank god they get rid of this cgi
jesus it was so goofy now we get this
guy as the dark one which is fine he's
fine i don't know i don't have an
opinion about everything i do however
think that his costume makes him look
like a waiter rand stabs himself to get
out of the dream while brandon moraine
are going along we see lord aglemar who
is defending faldera from what is
turning out to be a massive attack from
the dark one they are some of the last
defenders from the growing blight now it
looks like a hopeless cause but they are
still going to defend their home later
lord aglemar and lady emelisa have a
little chat about how they will defend
the city this stuff is fine but really
requires more build up we know so little
about these characters and care even
less if they had at least two episodes
to build up the stakes establish the
siege and give us characters to care
about that'd be great this whole episode
reeks of rushing all at once so much
needs to get delivered and we are too
busy jumping from one moment to the next
to really ask why why is it happening
like this almost like they're trying to
distract us from the weak storytelling
reminds me of that one movie moraine and
rand make it to the eye of the world and
the show never makes it totally clear
what exactly it is oh it's basically the
dark one's prison they go down the hole
and rand says he remembers this place
from his past lives then he has a
long-ass hallucination where he sees his
ideal life living a simple existence in
the two rivers raising a family with a
grain this it turns out is an extended
trap to lower rand to the dark side
while this is going on the evil waiter
disconnects moraine from the one power
more on that later and moraine is like
i'll kill this [ __ ] kid if he joins
you i literally don't give a [ __ ] i
wanted to kill this whiny [ __ ] for
eight [ __ ] but we now see our trollic
threat and oh boy is it a step down from
episode one
[Applause]
i'm not going to linger on the bad cg
too long because it was clear the
artists just weren't given enough time
i'm more upset about the bad blocking
and planning of this battle sequence it
all feels rushed and very removed from
reality while everyone is fleeing the
city aguain and naive stay to fight they
join the other magic users by entering
from
somewhere also why are they waiting for
the army to get obliterated couldn't
they stand on the wall they turn out to
be so overpowered i can't help but feel
like many people died for no reason
while everyone is fighting or standing
karen complains that being a pacifist is
unhelpful what are we supposed to do
just watch our friends die loyal's like
hey man you can still help out without
killing people you know so perrin goes
and helps them dig up the horn of velir
let me hold on
the horn of failure meanwhile rand is
having the longest hallucination known
to man the dark ones like oh yeah join
me and you'll be so happy and have tons
of sex yeah man and moraine's like i'm
not kidding i'll kill this [ __ ]
[ __ ] this goes on for a very long
time paddin fain the guy who has just
been standing around since episode 1
finally does something he gets into
faldera with some fades and peron
finishes digging up the horn of velir
this is meaningless except to set up the
second season readers know that the horn
was actually found at the eye of the
world so why valdera has it is anyone's
guess it's confusing if you haven't read
the books and it's confusing if you have
and honestly it's just unnecessary for
this moment the whole army gets
obliterated by trollock so now aguain
night and eve and the others are like
guess we gotta use magic now they link
up to the one power and a beam appears
in the sky a beam
they destroy the whole army
yeah
it was that easy oh one problem though
uh the one power is killing them all one
by one and it looks like naive is dead
totally dead definitely permanent
definitely totally 100 dead or maybe she
isn't how many times have they done the
fake out death of course at this point
it feels like anything can be reversed
as long as it suits the writer's needs
this was a completely unnecessary moment
that felt very cheap meanwhile rand is
still in his fantasy getting absolutely
nothing accomplished how will rand fight
back well he catches on to the dark
one's plan he realizes that aguain would
never be happy settling down with him
what about when she wants as much as i
want this
i know that she doesn't this is supposed
to act as some kind of character arc i
think but it feels pointless and has at
many points accepted who a gwain is and
respected her wishes in episode one when
she said she had to be a wisdom he
understood yes he was being petty
throughout but his understanding of
aguain hasn't really changed it all
feels cheap and heavy-handed like they
didn't have a better resolution to his
art rand very easily destroys the dark
one as he grins which makes it feel like
a false victory like maybe the dark one
was planning this all along it all feels
like a waste imagine a scene like in the
book rand enters a hallucination and is
so powerful he actually decimates the
raiding forces without even realizing it
in the show the ice sedai and training
destroy the army and it feels like rand
does nothing naive still feels more
powerful than the dragon reborn imagine
how cool it would be if we didn't know
who the dragon was until the very end
then ran just goes insane and destroys
an army everyone is speechless we would
finally see what is truly scary about
the dragon instead of just being told
about it after the dark one vanishes pat
and feign kills loyal
a major character in the books in order
to steal the horn stealing the horn is
accurate to the second book but killing
loyal in an interview show runner rafe
judkins says loyal is not actually dead
but fans were still justifiably outraged
why so many fake deaths it literally
just serves the moment moment while
losing the integrity of the larger show
again it feels cheap when parent picks
up his axe to fight pat and feign he
says
ah there you go
tiniest portion you choose the dog i
don't know none of this makes perrin
look especially great there's just no
payoff for the wolves you'd think the
wolves would come in and help him out or
something but no listen there's nothing
like that to wrap it up we get a green
screenshot of matt in an ambiguous
location maybe it's shidar lagoth i
don't really know clearly doing
something mischievous because the show
wants to make us know that they didn't
forget about him randa tells moraine
that he won't return to the others
because of how dangerous he is and she's
like okay go for it she tells lan who
finally gets there that she has been
disconnected from the one power because
you know we need drama for next season
our final teaser for the whole show is
this
the sean chan
apparently they really hate this random
girl on the beach they just really don't
like her and there you have it folks the
end of season one of the wheel of time
what can we take away from this mess
that has some fine moments some welcome
interpretations and a whole lot of
misguided storytelling for longtime
viewers of the man carrying thing
channel you know i rarely make videos
longer than 30 seconds for some reason i
felt compelled to make a video about
this show not because it's the worst
thing ever made but because i and so
many others couldn't define exactly what
was wrong with it politics like always
made the whole situation even more toxic
to me it all comes down to the writing
the adaptational choices were important
and cursed the show from the start but
that wasn't all there are some great
videos by the way and channels that
cover just the adaptational aspects i'll
link that below to me it all comes down
to stagnant characters bad pacing and
halting progress how did our characters
change and grow let's look at the
character arcs for season one rand's
character arc isn't so much that of
self-acceptance like in the book but of
accepting that aguain wants to be an
aysada he basically came to terms with
that in episode one that's really her
character arc accepting she can have
both naive learns to trust a little more
but peren stays the same lan opens up
more to naine and what his moraines are
i'm not even saying lan and moraine need
arcs in season one in the book they're
supporting characters especially lan as
the adults in the room they are mostly
stable and reliable the story isn't
really about them this is an issue in
the show our showrunner even talks about
the issue of setting up lan and moraine
in season two when they are mostly
absent in the second book they should
have never been treated like primary
characters this is like adapting the
hobbit and making handoff more important
than bilbo oh wait all this leaves me to
ask is there any hope for the second
season i mean
i hope so i do not want to see this fail
i hope the success of the first season
gives amazon the confidence to give them
even more money and time for the second
season this video took a long time to
make and i want to thank surfsharkvpn
for sponsoring it thank you viewer for
watching i love making this type of
long-form content but uh struggled to
find the time because i'm
a full-time student if you like this
stuff and want more please consider
signing up to my patreon because i want
to be able to make this type of stuff
regularly thank you to my patrons for
sticking through thick and thin thank
you thank you thank you uh and i thank
you for everyone for supporting the
channel i can't believe we're almost at
100k that's insane yeah so thanks
everyone bye bye